hello everyone and welcome to one of
those games that uh just has the first
15 moves to be a completely known theory
but um the game really explodes and it
explodes even before we reach unknown
territory uh but
such is the way of the real opus so i'm
pretty sure you guys will enjoy this one
let's check it out it's mvl with the
white pieces against fabiano caruana in
round four of this year's super bit
chess classic so mbl uh has the white
pieces and he opens with e4 we have e5
by fabi knight f3 knight to c6 and
bishop to b5 the real lopez is on the
board we have a6 uh morphy's defense and
now that bishop to a4 we have knight to
f6 castles and now we're going for this
uh knight captures an e4 now this is
again a very standard idea been been
played many times so nothing out of the
ordinary here d4 we have b5 chasing the
bishop bishop to b3 and now d5 so giving
back the e5 pawn the captures on e5 and
now the shorter e6 so again uh many many
games in the database with the exact
same uh position we have c3 bishop to
see five five develops the bishop to
this beautiful diagonal and puts more
pressure on the f2 pawn which is usually
not a big deal because you never want to
capture on f2 and give up two pieces for
a rook however this is one of the
openings uh where you actually want to
do that so knight b to d2 attacking the
knight here we have castles and now
bishop the c2 putting more pressure on
the knight here and now fabi goes for
the uh for the f2 pawn knight captures
on f2 rook captures and now uh okay here
the uh
most common idea is f6 you want to open
up
df file for the rogue but here five just
captures on f2 first king captures and
now f6 now again nothing new this has
all been played before knight to f1 we
have f captures on e5 opening up
a df file for the black rook king to g1
and now queen to d7 developing the queen
connecting the rook so we have bishop to
g5 and now there is a game where e4 was
played but here we have rook 8 the e8 by
fabi and it is now as of move 16 that we
have a completely new game
so what's uh uh the the idea behind the
position well fabi gave up a bishop and
the knight for a rook so there's that
but he has a very very strong center you
can see that his spawns are controlling
all of these squares the rooks are very
nicely placed and uh okay the the queen
is a little bit um uh hemmed in by the
bishop the knight still has to figure
out what to do but all in all it's a
very nice position uh for both white and
black but fabi says i probably know more
about this position than you do so queen
to d2 nvl develops the queen prepares to
bring the rook into the game and then
now comes d4
interestingly if you try e4 which seems
like it's uh more forcing as you're
putting pressure on the knight we can
play knight d4 and since black doesn't
really want to trade 95 let's say now
we're just gonna play knights to e3 and
it's a very very nice position for for
white you've blockaded the pawns uh
not all that much to worry about next
you're going to bring the rook into the
game
and so on you're gonna play b4 at some
points to prevent c5 uh not all that
much for for black to do here however uh
d4 uh five this is what fabi prepared
now comes knight to g3 again you can see
how the bishop and knight are nicely
controlling these squares so you you you
can just allow black to do whatever he
wants uh h6 now challenging the bishop
and the bishop to h4 here mvl is uh
daring fabi to play g5 but if you play
g5 then nothing really is happening
we're just gonna trade here and captures
captures and captures and after queen g7
uh you can even get to this end game uh
where uh well white really has nothing
to to show for here so instead we have d
captures uh on c3 but black also
wouldn't be able to push for for
anything uh and now comes queen captures
on c3 we have rook captures on f3 and
this is a very interesting uh decision
by fabi uh you don't have to capture the
rook you could also advance the pawn to
b4 maybe a nice inclusion also knights
to d4 is always an idea trying to win
that d4 square
but rook captures on f3 is definitely
the most interesting one so this is what
fabi plays and now his idea is if queen
captures an f3 then knight d4
is very close to winning for black
you're attacking the uh queen and the
bishop here and once the queen moves
knight captures and c2 is the idea and
now uh white should really trade queens
and that's just it black is just better
because if you capture the knight and
then queen to d4 with check king h1 we
pick up the bishop here and after queen
captures and c7 we get to this position
where um fabi would be up upon but it's
a really really bad uh
position for uh uh for mvl uh there's
the past pawn there's the the bishop
against the knight uh it's it it's just
better for black
so uh instead after this rook captures
an f3 uh mvl is forced to play g
captures on f3 and now we have knight to
d4 again putting pressure on the bishop
and on the f3 pawn we have bishop to d1
uh this is a very annoying move for for
fabi and the very clever defense by mvl
this bishop now totally totally
dominates the knight on d4 the problem
is you still can't get your rook into
the game and it's definitely something
you should do so rook to f8 putting more
pressure on the f3 pawn and now knights
to e4 preparing knight to c5 to attack
the queen and the bishop
and here bishop to c4
uh this is a a a very very important
move for for fabi's attack as you'll see
later on uh and now king to g2 here
bishop to f2 is actually extremely
strong as there is no good way for black
to continue playing this but it's such a
such an engine move that um of course
no one would really think of it but now
there's not all that much you can do
just bishop captures on d4 will be
played and that is sufficient for white
but okay those are engine ideas we have
king to g2 now adding more defense to
the f3 pawn you know that this pawn will
get attacked now
rook to f4 attacking the bishop and now
bishop back to e1 and now you can see
how the uh here the bishop pair is is
pretending to to be a king and queen
which is not something we see very often
i don't think we've seen this maybe once
or twice but not very often and while
it's not
great to have your bishops placed like
this here it actually works very well
for for maxine and here we have queen to
f5 again piling up on this f3 pawn and
the problem is this is very very
difficult to survive fobby's attack is
very strong however there is one move
that doesn't just survive the position
but also wins the game for maxine so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find this idea while i give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on realizing that the
f3 pawn is not defended sufficiently
even though we're defending it three
times and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is knight to d2
this is the only way to uh to win the
game now we are defending the f3 pawn
four times and that's exactly what we
need uh to give you an example of why
this is so let's play let's say you play
something like queen e3 so you just want
to see what what black's threat is uh
it's actually just capturing an f3 and
now after bishop captures an f3 it seems
like you've you know given up a piece
for nothing there's this bishop to f1
check this is why fabi's bishop on c4
was so nicely positioned as this bishop
to f1 is uh just a well a brutal idea of
course if king captures on f1 then we're
just going to win the game rook captures
on f3 we win the white queen so you're
gonna have to move the king king f2 and
now we go into this uh well we can go uh
we can go many many ways but queen to h3
is the way to go and this is how fabi
would uh
continue and uh keep the position alive
now the threat of queen to g2 checkmate
is just too strong as the bishop will
not be able to move and there is no
defense other than to give up the queen
here queen captures e captures and now
you have this position uh where okay uh
black has a queen but mvl does have uh
two pieces and the rook for the queen so
with perfect play uh should
should be a draw uh so that's why you
have to be very very careful or you you
can draw or you can even lose
but after knight to d2 the move that
maxine played the position is now
completely winning and there is nothing
more you can try here so fabi adds
another attacker with a move e4 he now
attacks the f3 point once again but we
are already defending it four times so
it's not a problem bishop g3 we attacked
the rook e captures an f3 with check and
now of course we just play king to f2
that's the critical move uh as now uh
black does not have a a single move to
to threaten anything so here and the
rook of course is hanging so rook to g4
now comes knight captures and c4 now we
can start uh uh trading pieces and
eliminating uh attackers by one by one
uh b captures on c for in now bishop
captures on f3
so the bishop here again sufficiently
defended we have knight captures on f3
queen captures on f3 and here queen to
c2 with check of course uh fabi doesn't
want to trade he's down a piece and of
course the end game will be winning for
maxime so queen e2 we defend check but
also if the queen moves we can just
capture the rook so we have to move with
check queen f5 check king the g1 and now
h5 fabinho has to try anything at his
disposal because uh well he's down a
full bishop and once rook f1 is played
then that's pretty much it there's
nothing more for fabi to look for rook
f1 was played and now we have queen to
g6 if you play queen c5 check just queen
f2 there's nothing to be uh done about
this and there's even the the very
interesting queen captures now you don't
even have to capture with the king you
can even play rook captures and after h
for seemingly winning the bishop there's
a rook to f4 so you can even have some
fun while you're winning this way but of
course fabi says this sees this he plays
the queen to g6 yeah of course this is
still a threat now king h1 not allowing
this uh to lose a bishop uh h4 attacking
the bishop now comes the bishop captures
on c7 and h3 so uh if uh mvl is not
careful fabi will have some checkmating
ideas along the back rank as the pawn is
covering the g2 pawn but of course mvl
will not allow this queen f3 queen to d3
fabio offers a queen trade hoping that
maybe the past the d-pawn will be
something that can save the game but not
just bishop to e5 we have rooked the g
to end bishop to c3 and he was in this
position on move 39 uh that fabiana
corona resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here he had some
30 seconds on the clock yes he still
needs to make one more move to reach
down control but it's some it doesn't
really matter what move he makes his
position is just terrible and he knows
it and of course he resigns here so just
to give you an example uh if you trade
here then there's really no point in
trying this there's no threat you can
make next move rook captures an h3 is
coming in white is just up too much
material and if you somehow try to keep
the queens on the board let's say you
play queen c2 you go after the h2 pawn
again we just captured the pawn there's
nothing to there's nothing to hope for
here white's position is just too strong
the b pawn is protected by the bishop
the bishop also is an attacking piece
it's very easy to just play queen f5 you
know threaten pretty much everything uh
that's not that but there's really
nothing for for black to look for here
so of course after bishop to c3 favi
resigns and what a great victory for
maxine bashir lagrav who i believe takes
the lead in the tournament not all games
are finished from round four uh but for
the moment he is uh the leader
so really really an exciting one as
you've seen even though uh uh up until
this move rook 88 uh basically 16 moves
of known theory uh
there was quite a lot of happiness in
the game
sacrificing on f2 giving up two pieces
for the rook then fabi even decided to
go for this rook captures an f3 idea
which he didn't have to play he could
have just continued normally with
knights to d4 or b4 but he wanted uh
he wanted to really play beautiful chess
and well it all came down to the
beautiful uh move with the knight back
as that move is usually what your
opponent will overlook and what will win
the game for you so when in trouble uh
look for a move with the knight back it
just might be the winning idea uh so
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
very nicely done by by mvl uh but as i
always say it takes two to play a great
game so we are of course grateful to
both of them for playing like this uh i
would like to thank queen c bonifate
alberto chandrasekhar
wrong thing for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing to cover this wonderful event
until it finishes
so thank you i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your sunday